oh yeah you go ahead are you sure yeah
yeah no problem thank you isn't there
just gonna watch me get coffee this is
so intimate
oh yeah yeah hey
interesting seating choice sir
why did you sit next to me when there
are all these empty chairs this
definitely means something you know what
this meeting is about yeah hey Chris
come on sit over here oh hey what's that
yeah no I can't I can barely move right
whatever I'm super busy freeze well
hello such a coincidence twice in one
day
I think he's obsessed with me humans
coffee huh a very small bladder
what
he's touching me hey um Ned was looking
for you
oh yeah he's finally ready to tell me
his true feelings I think he just wanted
you to email notes on that meeting okay
yeah mmm you should doing the company
softball team it's a lot of fun I don't
know how to throw things oh sure wait is
he trying to spend time with me outside
of work Oh Nick you know how throw
things oh hell yeah yeah you're in
we got a person okay too late I guess
should have said yes he wants to see me
outside of work Ned had a lot of really
great things to say about you oh really
you be Ned thinks our boss wants us to
fall yeah he said you really just took
initiative and took control on that last
project that's great I could just grab
him and kiss him in conference room B
this way to our meeting all right thanks
just thinking about the project oh yeah
I bet he planned his exit so it would be
at the same time as me that's so
romantic
we're gonna say yes
do you think Justin quints are secretly
dating I don't know isn't that against
company policy super subtle net I don't
think I don't care who cares I wouldn't
care
follow your heart oh hey do you want to
get drinks later
sure awesome oh man thanks for coming
elephant had a hot day later or
something
hey everybody cool boss is here shots
all around Jenny
yeah alright alright yep yeah
Wow